we love you as Wonder Woman gal gadot
it's hard to imagine anyone else trying
to wear your tiara you're a lot like
Princess Diana in real life you trained
in the Israeli army and won the title of
Miss Israel when you were just 18 years
old now that's impressive gal gadot is a
lot like Wonder Woman
she's smart brave and kind and she's got
a few secrets of her own keep watching
to find out which actress gal wanted to
play Wonder Woman's love interest in the
sequel during an interview with et gal
gadot admitted to tearing up while
watching an early screener of Wonder
Woman 1984 she explained that she wasn't
someone who gets emotional easily and
yet something about the film caught her
off-guard watch until the end to find
out which scene brought tears to gals
eyes gal and Kristen are all set to play
on-screen rivals but did you know this
isn't their first time working together
in 2010 gal and Kristen starred in date
night together Kristen Wiig was director
patty Jenkins first choice when it came
to Casting cheetah but even then the
role was first offered to Emma Stone
luckily for Kristen Emma declined
whereas DC's Wonder Woman has appeared
in both animated and live-action
adaptations the same can't be said about
cheetah Kristen Wiig is the first person
to portray the villain in her
live-action form
gal gadot and patty Jenkins revealed
some very interesting facts during the
2019 comic-con experience in South Paulo
Brazil according to them the Wonder
Woman sequel is technically done keep
watching to find out why the highly
anticipated film's release date was
pushed back a total of four times
Princess Diana might have fallen for
Steve Trevor in the first Wonder Woman
film but producers want fans to know
that Diana Prince swings both ways she's
all set to have a female partner in the
sequel and gal gadot wanted her
on-screen crush to be played by Halle
Berry gal gadot loves performing her own
stunts but this proved to be a difficult
thing to do while filming Wonder Woman
1984 unfortunately for gal the sequel
left her with a few spinal in
but that's nothing that Wonder Woman
can't recover from if there's one thing
that sets the sequel apart from the
original it's the wirework it's like
nothing anyone has ever seen before
gal admitted to performing many of her
own stunts with the help of advisers
from Cirque du Soleil Wonder Woman 1984
is all set to premiere on June 5th 2020
but it was originally supposed to hit
the big screen in November of 2019 the
sequel was pushed back to prevent it
from overlapping with Star Wars the rise
of Skywalker
and to the new James Bond film Gao
didn't reveal why she cried while
watching the screener of the sequel but
she did say that it was the first scene
that moved her to tears according to gal
the sequel starts off with a bang
the opening scene hit close to home for
gal who was born and raised in Israel
here at the things we post daily videos
about your favorite celebs movies and TV
shows so hit that subscribe button and
turn on those notifications if you
haven't already go into your YouTube
settings and switch on notifications if
you're watching on mobile this way you
can be the first to comment on our
videos and that's a wrap on the 10
secrets about gal gadot Wonder Woman
1984 movie how do you think Steve Trevor
was brought back to life sound off in
the comments